Candidat suivant, s'il vous plait.
Bonjour, bonjour.
Entrez, entrez, asseyez-vous.
Bien ! Merci d'être venu et puis bah,
pour commencer, je vais vous demander votre nom ?
Batman
Batman. D'accord.
Euh... B.A.T.M.A.N. ?
C'est ça.
...A.N. ! D'accord.
C'est pour faire "homme chauve-souris", c'est ça ?
Oui.
D'accord. C'est marrant.
Donc, si je me trompe pas, vous venez pour le poste d'assistant, c'est ça ?
D'associé !
Non, non. Assistant !
Ah, sur l'annonce c'est marqué "Associé" !
Oui, bah, c'est une erreur.
Bref, quelles sont vos particularités?
Qu'est-ce que vous pouvez apporter un peu dans cette histoire ?
Alors, pour commencer, j'ai une cape
que j'ai élaboré moi-même et quand je fais comme ça, je plane sur plusieurs mètres.
D'accord.
Moi, je vole.
Voilà. Euh...
Vous avez autre chose?
J'ai un grappin.
Je m'en sers surtout pour euh...
Pour grimper sur le toit des bâtiments, d'accord.
J'ai bien compris. En fait, moi, pour faire ça, je vole.
C'est-à-dire que je pars d'en bas et je...
Ok sinon j'ai une Batmobile et sa
spécificité c'est que...
Non non attendez. Je suis désolé.
Je vous coupe mais en fait ... moi tout ce qui est moyens de locomotion,
,ça m'intéresse pas parce que...
Je vole.
Et s'il pleut par exemple ?
Bon. Sinon...
Niveau bagarre, comment vous vous en sortez ?
Techniques de combat ?
Ah bah alors là, là, je suis imbattable justement, tout ce qui est corps à corps... Disons que je maîtrise quoi.
D'accord, donc si y'a un monstre géant qui attaque la ville, vous pouvez gérer ?
Etant donné que j'aurai besoin de développer du matériel spécifique en laboratoire,
j'aurais besoin de juste un
petit peu de temps pour analyser
la structure moléculaire de la créature,
mais oui, ça devrait pas poser de problèmes.
Non mais là, on parle ... combat rapproché. Vous contre la créature, à mains nues, quoi.
Ah ouais...euh...bah, euh...non...
Euh... D'accord.... Euh...
Mais vous avez affronté qui par exemple ?
Euh... Le Joker ?
Ah oui, c'est le monsieur qui s'habille en clown c'est ça ?
C'est le monsieur qui s'habille en clown...
D'accord...
Et bah... Très bien ! Très bien.
Et sinon, niveau armes, vous avez quoi ?
Euh, euh, un boomerang ...
Ah non non non, j'ai une arme mieux que ça, j'en ai une énorme mais là
elle est à la maison parce que... c'était pas pratique en fait à déplacer à cause du fait qu'elle est...
Qu'elle est trop puissante, quoi.
Ah oui, c'est vous qui tirez des lasers avec les yeux, c'est ça ?
Non, ça c'est vous.
Oui. Oui, c'est moi.
Euh... Très bien ! Merci d'être venu et puis, si vous êtes retenu pour le poste d'assistant...
D'associé.
Euh... d'assistant, ma secrétaire vous rappellera.
Au revoir monsieur ... ?
Batman.
Voilà c'est ça ! La p'tite chauve souris !
Allez ! Au revoir !
Candidat suivant, s'il vous plaît.
Asseyez-vous, je vous en prie.
Vous venez de croiser le candidat précédent, ça s'est...
pas très bien passé, j'espère que vous allez relever le niveau.
Alors avant de commencer, je vais vous demander votre nom.
Euh ... Hulk?